[Music]
[Music]
uh
technique
[Music]
today the european union and the united
states have concluded negotiations to
adjust the european union's world trade
organization
agricultural quotas following the uk's
withdrawal from the eu
this is the culmination of two years of
negotiations in the wto framework to
devise these
eu quotas with part of the volume
remaining in the eu
and part of it they go into the uk based
on
recent trade figures the agreement
covers
dozens of quotas and billions of euros
of trade including for beef
poultry rice dairy products fruits and
vegetables and wines
you will find further information in our
online press release and our daily news
thank you very much that brings us to
the end of our announcements for today
and we will now move to your questions
and i start
with marina
uh hi hello eric thank you for the
question i have a question for
peter and it's regarding the belgian
piston dialogue
which uh is celebrating 10th anniversary
today
and what is your question yeah uh my
question for
my question is can peter in front of
eu as a main facilitator of this
dialogue give us some
assessment of the reach so far was this
intend to last so long as one decade so
far
and what are the main accomplishments
from um as you can see and what it would
be
the message to better than priesthood at
this moment
thank you marina peter thank you
good afternoon and i hope you hear me
without the echo we have
weaver we were hearing with uh marina
so first of all uh the 10th anniversary
of the
eu facilitated uh belgrade pristina
dialogue the
eu special representative miroslav
lichak was
in the region last week both in kosovo
and in serbia to hear exactly from both
sides their assessment of the dialogue
and how they see the continuation of the
dialogue
and he was reassured that there is a
willingness on all sides to engage
in this eu facilitated dialogue now when
you ask about the achievements
the long-term objective of the dialogue
is to bring both parties serbia and
kosovo closer to the european future
and the european path of kosovo and
serbia goes
through the dialogue over the past 10
years the dialogue
um hold on peter we seem to have some
big
sound issues uh today everybody is
reporting
uh that there is an echo um
[Music]
so we'll wait to see if we can find a
technical solution and then
i will ask you to answer the question
again the sound completely
hold on
we try again okay peter try again
okay so i'll try to just continue
because i think the first part was
was quite uh audible unless you tell me
otherwise
go ahead okay so basically i was saying
that the eu high representative
aou special representative linchuk was
on the ground last
week just to see with both parties um
how they want to proceed uh there is an
understanding that the dialogue has no
alternative and it's really crucial for
peter i'm sorry but we we still have an
echo for some
for some reason reason
at least for some of our is there
something that people can do
okay peter third attempt go ahead
third time lucky so the the aim of
um eu special representative leichhardt
who went uh
both to pristina and to belgrade last
week was to assess and to see with both
parties with the serbian counterparts
and kosovo counterparts how they want to
proceed
there is an understanding that the
dialogue has no alternative and it's
crucial for
the normalization of their relations
because the european path
for kosovo and for serbia goes through
the eu facilitated dialogue and through
the normalization of the relations
now marina when you were asking about
the impact or the achievements over the
past 10 years
the dialogue has made a real difference
for the lives and well-being of citizens
in the western balkans
but after 10 years it is really time to
move forward now and bring this process
to a successful end
and this is why we are working so
closely and so intensively with the two
parties on a comprehensive agreement
to normalize relations between kosovo
and serbia and the member states of the
european union they expect
this dialogue to continue soon to resume
soon
and to see belgrade and pristina engage
in earnest to bring this process
to a successful end rather sooner than
later
thank you are there other questions for
peter on
the dialogue between belgrade and
christina
lawrence you have a question on this
hi there can you hear me yeah we can
hear you go ahead right yeah just just a
quick one peter apologies
this was asked the last week
but kirti made um some comments to euro
news about a greater albania and
uh being a supporter of the greater
albania and the possibility of
referendums on this in the future um
have you guys commented on this and uh
um
and uh said whether that's something
that you um
that the eu feels uncomfortable with at
all
thank you laurence the eu special
representative while holding talks in uh
prishtina had opportunity to speak with
mr corti as well and to discuss all the
issues
that are there in order to move the
dialogue ahead
when it comes to specific remarks made
by specific politicians either in the
media or somewhere else
you know that we usually don't comment
on them but generally speaking the
political leaders in the region they
should
lead by example in promoting the climate
of mutual trust fostering good
neighborly relations and regional
cooperations uh
cooperation which are principles the eu
is standing for
and we expect as the european union
everyone in the region to continue to
build constructive
and cooperative relations and to focus
and intensify work on their own
respective reform programs to move
forward on the european integration path
and this also goes for kosovo which has
clear european perspective that has been
repeated several times
and we expect the new institutions in
kosovo to work
in this direction and we will continue
also to work with all partners in the
region bilaterally
on their respective european path and
towards closer and more effective
regional cooperation and collaboration
based on all those principles which i
enumerated
and leading by example by promoting the
climate of mutual trust is
one of them lawrence you have a
follow-up
yeah i i just like to push push back to
peter on this
because he got quite a lot of attention
over the last few days the uh the much
loved rick
grinnell pitched in on this on this
issue
um peter when when it was a question of
um
land swaps uh and that issue came up the
eu was very clear to say we oppose land
swaps
um that that would set off a uh a
negative precedent
in the region um and obviously any kind
of kosovo joining greater albania um
would be uh would would be a land swap
of a type
um so can you just give me a clear
answer
is it is this something that the eu
opposes
i think this issue has been closed long
time ago we've been discussing it uh
repeatedly i mean the main aim when it
comes to normalization of the relations
between kosovo and serbia is to achieve
a comprehensive
legally binding agreement that is in
line
that enhances also the original
stability that is acceptable to both
sides first of all and that is in line
with the iwaki so
this is the main focus of our
facilitation and both
sides know what is doable and what is
not doable
because in the end it needs to be
mutually agreed between the two parties
themselves
thank you are there other questions for
peter
on foreign affairs
will
uh hi can you hear me yes go ahead well
uh hi
i was just wondering for peter uh if you
had a comment on the
chinese foreign minister's remarks over
the weekend is
wang yi he said uh the eu and china are
not system
systematic rivals and china appreciates
the eu for upholding strategic autonomy
uh which critics say show beijing's you
know
joy of the eu not siding with the us
completely i just wanted to have a
comment
you see peter
china though yeah that's for nebulae
yes um i understand that you wanted us
to
comment on a comment by beijing um but
could you please repeat your question
because it was not
completely clear
uh yes do you have a comment on chinese
foreign minister wang yi's
remarks over the weekend
well i'm sorry but i mean as you know we
never comment on comments and our
position on china has been uh
we we have been extremely clear we have
repeated it at many uh
uh all the time hrvp
the president vanderbilt so i'm not sure
i can answer
any of uh your question especially
relating to a comment by a comment
on a comment absolutely i think our
position
on on china has been set out very very
clearly
and there are areas where we believe
that
cooperation with china is of the essence
for example when it comes to dealing
with climate change we know
that they are also a competitor
in the economic field and we have said
time and time again that
in certain areas they are a systemic
rival
in particular when it comes to forms of
governance but this position
is absolutely nothing new we have
repeated it here and in many other fora
time and time again let us continue on
foreign affairs i passed the floor
to mass
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
johnson
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
10
a question regarding could you give an
update on you know the
so-called vaccine passport what
the commission intends to do in the past
forward
now given you know member states
obviously have
some different views are you going to
continue to push for the passport
or not push for the passport i mean now
china is also talking about
some international vaccine passports
kind of a thing so are you
thinking about uh passport for just the
eu or shengen
area or internationally thank you
thank you very much we've answered this
question already a certain number of
times i think you'll have to wait
until the 17th of march which is the 14
date for adoption of our proposal by the
way we don't call it
the passport we call it the green
digital certificate
and it aims as the president has said
to provide information on the health
status
related to coveid of the persons
that will be carrying this certificate
exactly how it will then be used by
member states in order to
improve freedom of movement still needs
to be
defined and will be the subject
obviously
of conversations there is as you rightly
point out
an international cooperation dimension
to this
and these are all issues on which we
will come back later once the proposal
is on the table let's continue on the
issue
of vaccines and vaccination angela
yes good morning thanks for the
opportunity uh
yesterday kiril dimitriv which is the
ceo of the
russian company that makes the sputnik
said on the italian state tv
he talked about some enemies uh on a
global level
who are transforming the issue of
vaccines in a political
issue against russia i was wondering if
you have a comment on this
and but also i wanted to know as you
said last week that there are no
contacts
uh as far as i understood between the
european commission and the russian
authorities on sputnik
do you fear that russia could try to
make deals with each member states has
this guy
yesterday said that they are in contact
with italy and other member states and
they plan to have
20 collaboration by the end of june
uh thank you thank you angela no we have
no comment to make
on the comments that you are referring
to clearly the european union
is no one's enemy we try to be the best
possible partner
um with uh with countries around the
world obviously
we have our views and we have our
interests
when it comes to the vaccine strategy we
have commented on this
time and time again here we have a
european vaccination strategy focused on
a certain number
of vaccine producers
and this is what all member states have
signed up to
when it comes to to buying
vaccines from these producers there are
specific
produ procedures that allow them to
authorize for emergency use on their
territory
other vaccines it is then their
responsibility
and they bear also the legal liability
if they decide to move forward in that
direction
yanis
yes hi i hope you can hear me yes i want
to get back to
what david was asking because it seems
that
the assessment of 300 million doses for
the second quarter
is significantly lower than what we have
been told
by the president self even in an
interview she gave us about a month ago
um and my question is is that based on
the assessment that at least one of the
companies and i guess we can all
uh imagine which that company is
is not going to live up to its
commitments for the
second quarter as it failed to do so in
the first quarter as well
thanks it's based on all
the contacts which the commission has on
a daily basis
with uh with the different producers as
you know
we do not provide data on individual
companies
here in the uh here in the press room
let me point out
that we have always said that figures
on prospective deliveries are quite
violent
volatile and therefore need to be taken
with care
the president is trying to provide
updates every time
every time she can and these things are
going to continue to
are going to continue to evolve um most
uh most certainly so for the moment we
are aiming for
doubling of deliveries to eu member
states
um in the in the coming months compared
to what will have happened
in in march and we believe that that
shows that there is an upward trend in
terms of deliveries which will be very
helpful
for the member states in terms of their
vaccination strategies
oliver
hello um in light of
uh the uh
[Laughter]
the the the what was it i think a
facebook post by the hungarian
um let's see government spokesman or
government minister
general goulash about the modern
delivery schedule
is the commissioner still confident
modern is gonna stick to its
commitments to liv to deliver um
uh it's it's maxine's timely thank you
you will excuse us but we don't follow
the facebook posts
of every official uh working for a
member state in the european union
when it comes to uh the uh
to the delivery schedules first of all i
think we should not jump ahead of
ourselves
um we have just discussed um figures
uh for the uh for the fourth coming
month and
as i said we do not provide individual
analysis of the deliveries of of
companies
in these in these comments on
prospective deliveries
jorge
hello good morning i hope you can hear
me well because i'm having some
technical issues
so i'm going back to the 300 million
doses
because in late february vice president
xefco which said
after uh general first council that
300 million doses for the second quarter
were for the three vaccines already
approved
so excluding johnson and johnson so
given that himself he already
mentioned that johnson and johnson once
exclude was excluded i just want to
confirm
that this is the case with the figure
that the president gave in the in the
interview
okay i have just answered that question
i've said that we do not we're not
making distinctions
in the figures that we are providing
this is the president's comment
concerned
the overall estimates for deliveries
that
um that we are projecting for the uh for
the coming
uh for the coming months so it's it's
it's not based on
vaccines which are already approved or
not approved
you have a follow-up jorge
yeah sorry very quickly to confirm so
this is just based on the vaccines
already approved right
you say 100 million no no it's the
opposite
it's not based only on approved vaccines
it's the overall figure
it's the estimate for the overall figure
of deliveries
that we hope for the second quarter so
we're not making a distinction between
vaccines already approved
and vaccines not yet approved and as i
said
these are prospective figures which
may still evolve which is why we're
always extremely careful when we give
figures
on forthcoming deliveries
yes hello thank you eric besides the
issue of the
increase of deliverance and supplies of
vaccines to member states
i think another issue is of course the
logistics and the organization of the
vaccination center the united states uh
that we haven't commented so much on
that
but according to ecdc i heard that they
plan to issue a new let's say
report on that issue towards the end of
this month perhaps together with the
commission in fact so i would like to
also if you could
confirm that and when exactly will that
report be published thank you
stefan can you say anything on this yes
thank you very much
i don't think i can say anything on this
i invite you mostly to
contact ecdc of course you know that
vaccinations are national competences
are being followed and set up by the
member states you also know that
together with the commission we together
follow what is going on in the different
member states already in october
we shoot the first set of
recommendations regarding the
preparation of such a vaccination
campaigns we
continue to follow this also in the
context of the health security
committee but at this stage i don't
think i can give any further details
as to whether or not we will come out
with such a specific
text thank you thank you
santis
i just wanted to ask you does the
european commission consider
at all the political implications of
sputnik's authorization or you only
focus on the health aspect
i'm asking this question as we see an
increasing number of
balkan countries expressing frustration
with the eu and they officially turn to
russian and chinese vaccines i mean
where is the is there any political
aspects in the whole discussion or you
don't consider that at all
thanks this
political dimension in what sense i mean
i was very clear last week in saying
that when it comes to
the um the assessment process that emma
undertakes
on a vaccination and the market
authorization
which then comes if emma has given a
positive assessment
the only consideration obviously
is a health related one and it is
related to the safety and the efficacy
of any uh of any vaccine candidate
that is the only thing that we as
responsible public organizations can
uh take into account when looking at
a vaccine and i i think that that is
perfectly
uh understandable and perfectly
justified
follow-up scientists no
okay rafaela
ah sarantis does have a follow-up sorry
rafael sanchez go ahead
basically a couple of weeks ago the
commission president said that
well actually wondering in public why
russia is promising millions of vaccines
across the world
while it hasn't vaccinated its own
people so there is a
there was a clear sign of uh an attempt
to politicize it this is
how most people perceived it that's why
i'm asking this question
well that's not how i had understood
your question the president
referred to an obvious fact
uh related to percentages
of a vaccination i was answering on a
different issue
in terms of how we discharge our duties
and this is this is only based on what i
have just described to you
the fact that you can ask yourself
questions
on the the announcements that are made
on the willingness to deliver vaccines
to countries outside of russia is a
different is a different question as far
as we are concerned
the most important thing is that we have
put in place
as you know support for kovacs
in order to ensure that vaccines can
reach
low and middle income countries we also
have discussed
solidarity mechanisms with the member
states in order to
help our partner countries in particular
in our neighborhood
access vaccines and in that sense we are
showing our solidarity with the
with the rest of the world
tommaso or sorry no apologies rafaela
i had cut you off rafael you have the
floor
thank you eric may i just come back to
oliver's
question as i did not really get the
essence of the answer but i think we're
all quite interested
um in this topic um so apart from the
tweet
um or the mentioned tweet coming from
hungary
do you expect modena to fulfill the
deliveries
till the end of march so till the first
for the first
quarter thank you rafael my answer was
perfectly clear we do not
give assessments of individual companies
when it comes to deliveries
we have made certain comments when
public statements were made by the
companies themselves
or when we had comments to make on past
deliveries
but not on projections for individual
companies but of course we expect
all all companies to deliver
on their commitments as signed in the
advanced purchasing
agreement and that is why we are in
constant contact with them
on delivery schedules
tommaso
yes thank you for the floor of the
museum it's
just a follow-up on the same issue and
in the sense from the numbers
i guess that there is still a big
problem with astrazeneca
i know you don't comment on single
companies but
given that mario draghi decided
and the commission agreed to block the
exports
of 250 000
doses of vaccine to australia i wonder
if you have the impression
that astrazeneca got the message or not
thank you
look i'm not here to try to
to understand whether the management of
a company
gets a message or not that's really not
our role here on the podium
what is clear is that we have a policy
and that is geared at ensuring that we
have transparency
on exports of vaccines outside
of the european union and that
if possible member states and the
commission have ways
to to stop exports
if we had the impression that the
delivery of vaccines to european
customers
is not going um according to according
to plan
now you know about the decision which
took place last week
the context in which it was taken has
been discussed here in the press room
many many times
we have no further considerations to
make on the issue
okay i see no further questions for us
on
health related issues are there other
questions for us today michela
thank you
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
free movement is a fundamental freedom
we will continue to act
to ensure that the recommendations
adopted by the council are respected to
avoid
travel bans
mercy christie
the president
[Music]
[Music]
michelle
[Music]
m
do you hear me yes go ahead yeah thanks
uh mickey winner with the drum news
agency thanks i've got a question on
frontex and
um the conclusions of friday's
management board meeting
um i'd like to know what your position
is on the working group report
and what's going to happen next um and
could you please
explain or do you have an explanation
that almost one and a half year after
the new frontier regulation came into
force
there are still such substantial
deficiencies
thanks thank you
uh this is for adelberg i hope she could
hear you because the sun was not great
sun was not great
i i could hear you uh loud and clear
thank you thank you very much and thanks
um for this question in indeed having in
place
a european border and coast guard that
is strong effective and well functioning
is a priority for the commission
and the and from
of delivering on its mandate which is
set out in the law that
that entered into force in december 2019
and
i'm sorry but there was an interruption
when i asked you to start again
okay uh thank you so i i started by
recalling that
having in place a strong effective and
well-functioning european border and
coast guard
is a priority for the commission and
that frontex the agency has in this
respect
an essential task of delivering on its
mandate
that is set up in the law that entered
into force in december 2019
and that in fact builds upon previous
legislation
now uh as you as you recalled miguel on
friday
the management board met to consider the
report of the working group
that had been set up in order to look
into a number of issues
and the conclusions of the board and the
main report of the working group
are in fact publicly available but maybe
to recall some of the key elements
based on an assessment of the report the
conclusions
set out a number of next steps and a
timetable for the agency
to meet to address in fact urgently the
issues that have been identified
and in particular i can maybe quote that
the management board noted with concern
that the reporting systems currently in
place are not systematically applied
do not allow the agency to have a clear
picture of the facts relating to
potential serious incidents
and do not allow for a systematic
analysis of fundamental rights concerns
the agency needs to make urgent
improvements in in this respect
now when it comes to the commission's
position of course the commission is a
member of the
is a member of the management board and
as such supports these conclusions
and in fact the commission has been
raising
concerns about issues for example
regarding the reporting systems
and delays in relation to the
implementation of the agency's mandate
now for for a while and we've been
making sure that the management board
discusses these issues
so so that the agency can make progress
uh what we will do now is we will
continue to provide support and advice
to the agency
also at the technical level in order to
in order to make progress
we will also cooperate with the european
parliament scrutiny group which exists
and we we are committed to the success
of the agency
and when it comes to this your specific
question on the next
steps uh the next meeting of the
management board will take place in may
and the conclusions of the management
board make a number of requests
to the executive director for him to
meet
according to a timetable which includes
for example
a an expanded roadmap to be submitted to
the management board
uh three weeks ahead of the of the next
meeting in may
so the the commission uh remains very
strongly engaged
in uh in the success of the agency and
we will of course follow this issue
extremely closely
thank you adelbert are there other
questions for albert today
that is not the case so i give the floor
to rafaela who had another issue
raphael you have the floor
[Music]
um
[Music]
jack
hello hi jack go ahead hi i'm running
for the telegraph today uh
quick question on whether um the
european commission
feels that it is sulking whether there
is ill will
regarding uh relations with the uk after
this
debacle with uh with the northern
ireland staff and the
extension of the seaboard stuff
we never sulk we don't have moods
we are an institution so we try to work
on a day-to-day basis with a very very
even temper
any other questions for us today
that does not seem to be the case so
thank you very much and see you tomorrow
for the college readout